Incheon International Airport South
Korea's gateway to the world practically
deserted the aviation industry here is
decimated as it is globally with
predictions of a slow recovery aha
earlier we thought the industry would
recover 80 to 90 percent by the end of
the year but now we expect fifty to
sixty percent and even next year the
global market still won't be fully
recovered the parts of the world
emerging first from the virus are likely
to see their airline businesses pick up
quickest a number of countries in Asia
Pacific South Korea among them have won
international praise for the way they've
tackled the pandemic they've had to pay
a high economic price for tough travel
restrictions but the fact they're now
being eased is widely seen as a reward
for that effort so-called travel bubbles
allowing free movement between
neighboring states that have the virus
under control will help the process New
Zealand and Australia are considering
establishing one so we both stand to
benefit from getting travel up and
running again Hong Kong Macau and
mainland China could follow while a
fast-track system for business travelers
has been established between South Korea
and China so they can bypass quarantine
in accordance with the agreement they're
issued with a quarantine waiver if they
get tested at the airport and go under
active monitoring one of South Korea's
most prominent businesspeople the
Samsung Air J Wiley recently visited one
of his company's plants in China easier
travel is seen as important for economic
recovery with 90 percent of
international flights grounded we
understand the government is in talks
with other countries to enhance
cooperation the country and its Airlines
hoping for the day the departure board
won't look so empty Rob mcbride al
jazeera Incheon South Korea